la moto assassine trop de morts cet été
l'iran se déchaîne et menacent de rompre
avec moscou allen attila le cyclone se
dirige vers le texas
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
la route tue de plus en plus et
l'accroissement des accidents dont sont
victimes et les jeunes motards devient
inquiétant le ministre de la santé a
donné hier ce point de comparaison
chaque mois les morts par accident de
moto représente deux fois bologne
l'attentât qui a fait 79 morts en italie
samedi dernier philippe gassot c'était
un conducteur prudent il connaissait son
trajet par coeur aujourd'hui c'est
l'accident
arrivés en une fraction de seconde
je fais de la moto que problème le
trajet que je suis habituellement pour
aller à la police et je suivais une
voiture et je roule à doubler je n'ai
pas vu que qu'elle tourne et je n'ai pas
vu de signe au crédit elle tournait et
j'ai alerté ces gens là combien peut-on
chiffrer l'augmentation des blessés des
morts dont une augmentation d'environ 42
% sur les cinq premiers mois de cette
année qui a été encore plus importante
pour ce qu'on a fait dans le temps les
vélomoteurs que pour les motos de plus
de 125 mais c'est tout de même une
augmentation considérable qui suit une
augmentation de 30 % l'année dernière
sortons des statistiques ça fait combien
de morts ou blessés sur la route sur les
premiers mois on est passé de 150 à 200
morts pour les motos et comme la
circulation motorisée saisonnière si
l'augmentation secours suite ça peut
faire la fin de l'année 600 700 morts
le gros problème de la moto qu'elle soit
de grosses de petite cylindrée c'est
avant tout semble-t-il une question
d'incompatibilité avec le trafic est
autonome et particulièrement en milieu
urbain
pour les responsables de la sécurité
routière les motards deviennent de plus
en plus casse ou ne respectant pas les
règles élémentaires de la prudence les
usagers reproche aux pouvoirs publics de
ne pas aménager bien au contraire
le réseau routier pour les motos quoi
qu'il en soit on meurt sur 2 euros
pourquoi pensez vous que les jeunes se
tuent de plus en plus à moto
park
les motos
de plus en plus vite
jeunes acquièrent une moto de plus en
plus jeunes
il ya un an qu'un soldat vente
d'expérience est ce que vous aviez un
conseil et leurs données vocales et
d'expérience c'est à dire que j'ai fait
comme tout le monde j'ai pris des
risques si je pense que c'est une
question de
tab
à mesure qu'on prend de l'âge on prendre
là
les problèmes toi
c'est que
des couples on dansa s'agit quoi
tom comme vous se tue à moto est ce que
ça vous inquiète
j'essaie d'être prudent
moi j'en vois wii qui font des roues
arrière
en moto au monde
au risque de
le recteur ben moi
les chances sont inégales ce moteur a
passé un an et demi à l'hôpital un
accident de la circulation
votre terme entre le
faut le faire est ce que vous pensez
qu'un jour les motards au pouvoir
circuler en toute sécurité
tu vas falloir faire de la moto ailleurs
bah je pense que maintenant pour faire
de la moto si on veut vraiment faire de
la moto pour aller sur un circuit
selon des circuits il n'y en a pas
partout bien loin s'en faut et la moto
reste un moyen de locomotion
ce motard va trop vite en ville ce
serait l'hôpital à coup sûr
non on vient de vous voir vous avait
dévissé dans un virage ça qu'est ce qui
vous est arrivé pourquoi vous avez pris
un engagement annoncé l'otan si c'est
pour éviter ce genre de trucs sur la
route sur la route ils ont bien failli
voir son blouson ces actes ont besoin
déchire et après une passe de crasse et
arrière corvil aurait pu taper dans
l'oeil à lannion deauville les becs de
gaz sont venus
tous les motards vous êtes un peu
contestataire questions statistiques
pour nous parle aujourd'hui d'une
fréquence d'une augmentation du nombre
des accidents mais on nous parle pas du
doublage de parc moto la moto si elle
est bien comprise et si elle est faite
dans les endroits appropriés par exemple
ici au circuit carole
quatorze mille utilisateurs de la piste
depuis l'ouverture de jambe cassé une
clavicule moins qu'une piste de ski je
crois que c'est sa part de soi oui en
tout cas monsieur jacques barrot pour
monsieur jacques barrot le musée de la
santé les accidents de la route ne sont
pas une fatalité c'est un fléau qui peut
reculer
il suffit at il précisé que les français
le veuille pourquoi le prix de l'essence
ne diminuent t-il pas la pompe alors que
le marché des produits pétroliers subi
une baisse depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est le sens d'une question adressée
par monsieur laurent fabius le
porte-parole du parti socialiste au
ministre de l'économie on sait que les
belges et les suisses ont eu l'heureuse
surprise récemment de payer moins cher
leur carburant alors que les français
eux n'ont rien vu venir alors
l'explication philippe sassier un
cerveau d'autant une que je vous le
rappelle en quelques 18 mois les prix du
pétrole ont augmenté d'environ 150 %
alors qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
mais d'abord le dollar a baissé et comme
peillon autres pétrole en dollars nous
payons ce pétrole actuellement un petit
peu moins cher et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement n'a pas
répercuté sur les prix de l'essence les
dernières hausses des prix du pétrole
comme cela avait été annoncé pour le
début du mois d'août en quelque sorte la
baisse du dollar a annulé les hausses du
prix du pétrole blandine dire pourquoi
est ce que les suisses les belges se
voit vraiment le prix de leur essence
mais c'est bien beaucoup de pays
européens achètent directement sur ce
qu'on appelle les marchés libres comme
celui de rotterdam leur fioul est leur
essence
or actuellement parce que les que son
plein parce qu'il ya moins d'acheteurs
les prix de ce fioul et de cette essence
sur ces marchés libres a tendance à
baisser
la france elle a choisi comme politique
de se rendre plus indépendante à l'égard
de ces marchés libres et des grandes
compagnies pétrolières internationales
elle veut éviter justement ces
fluctuations de prix trop rapide et le
gouvernement a décidé c'est ça se fait
depuis 1928 d'imposer les prix en france
c'est lui qui les fuit justement afin
d'éviter ces évolutions en deux en dents
de scie l'an dernier par exemple quand
les prix flamber sur ces marib et bien
les allemands payer beaucoup plus cher
leur foulée leur essence que nous on a
calculé que si les allemands avaient
appliqué le système français il aurait
payé environ 20 à 30 milliards de nos
francs en moins la facture pétrolière
alors on peut discuter pendant longtemps
pour savoir quelle est la meilleure
politique en matière d'achats pétrolier
la française allemand de la neige ou la
suisse quoi qu'il en soit le
gouvernement a pour l'instant décidé
d'abandonner l'idée de libérer les prix
du carburant qui avait été décidée je
vous le rappelle pour le début de
l'année de cette année car le pétrole et
produits pétroliers c'est pratiquement
le dernier secteur qu'il a décidé de
surveiller toujours extrêmement
étroitement merci philippe sassier
social j'apprends que monsieur matteoli
le ministre du travail recevra le 20
août la délégation de la cgt qui avait
demandé audience au premier ministre
mais c'est le ministre du travail qui
recevra cette délégation
puis que la cfdt appellent à une grève
des ptt le 16 août dans certains
départements la cfdt protestent contre
le fait que le samedi 16 août ne soit
pas un jour chômé ce qui rompt le pont
évidemment du case boulogne sur mer
c'est toujours l'impasse dans le conflit
entre les armateurs et les marins
pêcheurs qui ont cessé le travail
les usines de poissons ne pouvant plus
fonctionner on parle de mise en chômage
technique de leur personnel pierre-marie
thiaville boulogne aujourd'hui n'était
plus un port de pêche tandis que les 45
chalutiers sont toujours bloqués à quai
qu'il n'ya donc plus d'arrivage de
poisson frais l'écoulement du poisson
déjà débarqué et conserver ses trouvait
lui aussi bloqué par les marins pêcheurs
qui ont établi autour des installations
de la halle à la marée des barrages
destinés à filtrer les camions par voie
de conséquence les mareyeurs qui
comptait cesser leurs achats aux halles
à partir de lundi l'ont fait dès
aujourd'hui parachevant ainsi la totale
paralysie du commerce de poisson dans le
premier port de pêche français
il est bien évident que dans les jours à
venir cette paralysie va atteindre les
industries en aval conserverie et
congélation qui joue un grand rôle dans
l'économie de la région boulonnaise
on ne voit pas encore ce qui pourrait
amener une issue rapide au conflit
l'intervention des pouvoirs publics
étant subordonné le ministre des
transports l'a rappelé ce matin à une
rentabilisation de la profession pour
les armateurs confrontés aux de
carburant cette rentabilité passe par
une réduction des équipages réduction
que les marins pêcheurs refusent
absolument
les syndicats cgt cfdt des marins ont
reçu aujourd'hui l'appui de ceux des
dockers c'est qui laisse craindre un
durcissement du conflit surtout si les
industries de conserverie privé de
matières premières sont contraintes à
des mesures de chômage technique dans
les jours à venir
c'est désormais officiel la police
judiciaire a un nouveau patron en la
personne de monsieur michel guyot qui
remplace monsieur jean ducret le départ
de monsieur ducret n'est pas une
surprise puisqu'il était atteint par la
limite d'âge sa carrière était restée
très discrète mais vous savez le nom de
monsieur ducret est apparu dans la
sphère de breuil
l'ancien directeur de la pj a été
entendu deux fois par la commission
parlementaire chargée de ce dossier
l'enquète sur l'attentât de bologne
n'avance guère
marco à faty gâteau le seul suspect
semblerait avoir un alibi que les
policiers dit soit vont devoir
maintenant vérifier le jour de
l'attentât
il aurait acheté des roses à une
fleuriste de nice le procureur de
bologne a déclaré qu'à faty gâteau était
seulement une personne qui pouvait être
utile à lenquête ce n'est qu'une des
nombreuses pistes at il ajouté quant à
l'organisation d'extrême droite
italienne noyau armées révolutionnaires
qui a revendiqué l'attentât
elle présente à faty gâteau comme un
mythomane et un délateur
autrement dit un indicateur de police
par ailleurs de madrid on apprend de
source officielle que les explosifs
utilisés dans l'attentât de bologne est
le même que celui employé par le thé à
militaires l'organisation basque contre
un autobus de la garde civile
le 22 janvier le 22 juin plutôt derniers
états unis le parti démocrate va
désigner la semaine prochaine à new york
son candidat à la présidence candidat
qui sera opposé à ronald reagan côté
républicain sauf imprévu c'est jimmy
carter qui devrait l'emporter après quoi
comment sera la véritable campagne et la
pêche aux voix
je rappelle que l'élection est prévue
pour le 4
neuf ans la pêche aux voix et bien une
communauté que tente de séduire dès
maintenant les candidats ce sont les
noirs les noirs américains sont en
grande majorité pauvre et se sentent
brimés
ils attendent en échange de leurs votes
des promesses de la part du plus offrant
jacques séguin et jean-louis saporito se
sont rendus dans le quartier noir de
boston nous sommes à quatre kilomètres
du centre de boston dans le quartier de
roxboro
derrière vous voici l'image
traditionnelle de boston mais suivez moi
nous dit isaac joueuse qui va nous
servir de guide et de caution
blackberry avec ses 53 mille habitants
est le ghetto noir de la ville les
blancs n'entre pas dans rex brille et
les noirs ne s'aventure plus dans le
quartier irlandais du sud boston cette
tension raciale est presque aussi
vieille que la ville mais depuis
quelques semaines elle fait redouter le
pire
on constate que l'écart s'élargit entre
les revenus des noirs et des blancs
malgré les efforts des années 60 je
pense que le pays vire à droite et les
programmes sociaux ont été délaissées
conte à rogner sur les budgets
si bien que ce sont les pauvres qui sont
pénalisés et ils sont en colère
les premières tensions se sont
développées au cours des dix dernières
années
surtout quand les nouveaux arrivants
noirs du sud sont venus jusqu'ici pour
chercher du travail pour accélérer
l'assimilation entre blancs et noirs
les autorités de la ville ont imposé il
y a 6 ans le système du bassing on
transporte des enfants noirs dans les
écoles des quartiers blancs et certains
blancs vont chez les noirs les résultats
aujourd'hui sont plutôt décevant car les
parents aisés envoient leurs enfants
dans les écoles privées et les noirs
sont furieux
mais aujourd'hui il y à plus grave
encore que cet échec important dit il
c'est qu'il ya des usines qui ferment
il ya des produits qui sont fabriqués à
taiwan par exemple ce n'est pas la
compétition avec l'étranger qui est
importante la menace pour nous ici ce
sont ceux qui sont très riches et se
moque du reste si vous prenez l'exemple
par exemple des compagnies américaines
et bien que font-elles ces compagnies
elles font fabriquer leurs produits à
l'étranger car c'est moins cher et nous
n'avons plus de travail
harold burry 44% des jeunes noirs sont
chômeurs et ici il n'ya pas de classe
moyenne noire mais des pauvres dont un
sur cinq est sans emploi
une situation qu'on retrouve à
washington détroit los angelès chicago
et new york
un malaise qui pourrait dans les
prochaines semaines se transformer en
défi à l'étranger encore proposition du
ministre ouest allemand des affaires
étrangères que les nations unies vote
l'interdiction de la peine de mort dans
le monde monsieur genser souhaite que
cette question soit examinée à l'automne
à l'eau et du message du président
sadate au président giscard d'estaing
remis hier à l'élysée ce message entrant
dans le cadre des contacts intensifs
entre le caire et paris après le vote
par le parlement israélien du nouveau
statut de jérusalem en terre de
l'ambassadeur tunisien à paris et dima
brook
après la libération de tous les détenus
politiques en tunisie at il précisé
mon pays s'engage dans une nouvelle et à
iran coup de colère de monsieur gods ad
devant le parlement israélien
voulons-nous respecter oui ou non les
conventions internationales
le ministre iranien des affaires
étrangères que vous voyez ici a dit
qu'il n'y avait pas incompatibilité
entre le respect des principes définis
par le prophète mahomet et les
conventions internationales qui n'ont
pas été vraiment respectée jusqu'à
présent at-il il ajouté devant les
parlementaires qu'il n'accepterait aucun
poste dans le prochain gouvernement
et puis l'iran menace de rompre ses
relations diplomatiques avec l'union
soviétique
si l'union soviétique ne suspend pas son
aide militaire à l'irak
vous savez que l'irak est en très
mauvais termes c'est moi qu'on puisse
dire avec l'iran que l'irak est aussi
allié avec l'union soviétique et bien
l'iran donc menace de rompre ses
relations
diplomatiques avec moscou on l'a appris
il y à quelques minutes
enfin en août jour pour en terminer avec
l'iran j'apprends aussi que monsieur
chapour bakhtiar l'ancien premier
ministre qui est à paris a décidé de
créer un mouvement de résistance
nationale iranienne et c'est une
déclaration qu'il a faite tout à l'heure
de son bureau par ici des précisions sur
l'aide du gouvernement français à
l'ouganda ont été donnés aujourd'hui par
l'elysée le plan qui dans une première
phase sera consacrée à l'art
distribution de vivres et de médicaments
sera opérationnel à partir du 18 août
mais il faut d'abord l'accord des
autorités ougandaises ce plan dure
environ un mois je rappelle que 3000
tonnes de céréales vont être acheminés
vers l'ouganda
et puis vous vous souvenez de cette
religieuse que vous voyez ici religieuse
française que vous avez vues dans le
reportage de philippe gassot et patrick
voix sur l'ouganda que nous avons
diffusé mercredi dernier
et bien sûr eliane et la seule
religieuses françaises à s'occuper des
affamés du karama jo dans le nordouest
du paris et puis je vous annonce qu'elle
sera notre invité dans le journal
d'antenne de midi de lundi puisqu'elle
est venu prendre quelques jours de repos
en france donc serez liane à 12h45 lundi
est par ailleurs quatre chanteurs
français
nicole croisille maxime le forestier
georges moustaki et catherine lara
après avoir vu ce reportage ont décidé
d'offrir un gala prochainement dont la
recette sera versée intégralement en
faveur des ougandais qui meurent de
l'université de vincennes déménager le
déménagement a lieu en ce moment puisque
les étudiants de paris 8 suivront leur
cours désormais à saint denis
un déménagement qui ne sait qu'il ne
signifie pas espère les professeurs les
étudiants un changement de l'esprit de
vincennes l'université de vincennes des
ménages techniquement déjà ce n'est pas
une mince affaire cent cinquante mille
livres plus de dix mille mètres cubes de
dossiers et matériels divers à emballer
et transportées cela représente une
vingtaine de camions par jour pendant
trois semaines l'opération coûteux se
déroule d'ailleurs sous la surveillance
discrète de la police
mais là n'est pas le vrai problème
paris huit universités pilotes nés des
événements de 68
la première à recevoir les non
bacheliers les salariés universités
contestataire est souvent contesté
occupé quatre hectares de terrain à
l'orée du bois de vincennes à la rentrée
à saint denis
elle devra accueillir ces quelques 35
mille étudiants dans des locaux plus
étroit mais aussi plus moderne plus
fonctionnel et surtout plus propre même
si les abords sont moins agréables et
dans ce transfert certains ont voulu
voir la volonté du gouvernement de
casser cette université turbulent ses
pères spirituels et ses enseignants
reste confiant même à saint-denis
vincennes sera toujours un cerf nous
partons à saint denis avec un certain
sentiment d'amertume mais c'est pas pour
autant que nous pensons que le
l'enseignement à saluer différent de
celui qui était à vincennes ce sont les
mêmes personnes ce sont les mêmes
méthodes sont laissés à eux mêmes et à
l'esprit qui je l'espère va va continuer
à prévaloir à saint denis
nous allons peut-être même profité de
cette de sept de ses déménagements pour
faire sa forme de bilan pédagogique
essayer d'améliorer encore la qualité
notre enseignement
je pense que ce qui doit distinguer
vincennes du razes universités c'est non
seulement cet accueil très diversifiés
aux salariés aux non bacheliers et c'est
aux mères de famille mais également et
surtout je dirais la qualité de son
enseignement et c'est je crois ce à quoi
nous allons tenter devrait dès la
rentrée je pense que nous sommes qu'un
épisode d'une d'une grande épreuve que
traverse toute l'université à travers
ces habilitations à travers cette crise
de moyens nous pensons pas que nous
sommes un destin particulièrement
exceptionnelle mais froid que nous se
sommes aussi la volonté une phase de la
volonté de l'université de survivre et
de
refusé qu'on lui impose une faille reste
un autre problème
on parle déjà de gâchis ces bâtiments
dont la valeur est estimée à 120
millions de francs seront rasées dans un
mois certes il avait été construit
rapidement et sans permis sur un terrain
appartenant à la ville de paris
mais pour le ministère des universités
propriétaire des murs
il n'y a pas d'autre solution il existe
une convention qui lie l'état à la ville
de paris convention signe indien 172
entre les deux partenaires et qui
précise que les looks les le terrain du
kili supporte l'université paris 8 à
vincennes doit être restitué en l'état
tels qu'ils étaient en 1968 il parle
d'autre part je vous ferai remarquer que
les locaux les bâtiments de 25 ans 12
ans d'âge et leur utilisation ultérieure
supposerait des réparations et les
améliorations très importante de l'ordre
de plusieurs milliards de centimes de
plus ces bâtiments ne répondent pas aux
normes de sécurité en vigueur
et ils sont dans un état pitoyable la
ville de paris a donc la ferme intention
de les démolir pour les remplacer par
des espaces verts
mais à tout hasard avant l'arrivée des
bulldozer elle enverra quelques experts
pouvoir si quelque chose peut encore
être sot a lyon un trafic d'hormones
destinés au bétail vient d'être
découvert plusieurs personnes ont été
inculpées la loi qui interdit l usage de
ces hormones cancérigènes sur des veaux
comme c'était le cas à lyon est trop
souvent transgresser cas ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'un tel scandale éclate
il ya quelques mois c'était à périgueux
cette fois-ci d'ensevelir quelques
semaines dans un mois environ il sera
bon pour la boucherie si avant de le
vendre
j'ai un plant sous sa peau ces quelques
granulés dos trop jeune en quinze jours
il prendra une bonne vingtaine de kilos
à 25 francs le kilo non bénéfice
supplémentaire sera de 500 francs par
tête
c'est ce calcul simple et rentable qui
est à la base du trafic qui dans la
région a provoqué l'intervention de la
justice
c'est le parquet de bourgoin qui
traite cette affaire est pour l'instant
cette absence du groupe est notre
affaire pour le moment paraît s'arrêter
là parce que sur ce plan
sur le plan actuel elle marque le pas
c'est à dire nous n'avons pas de
développement nous à partir de cette
affaire qu'ils soient prévisibles dans
un temps proche maintenant
pas vous dire s'il y aura d'autres
développements sur d'autres affaires ou
d'autres personnes qui ont pu utiliser
ou livrés à la consommation s'est
produit l'usagé des oestrogènes est
interdite en france depuis 1976
malgré la loi le trafic se poursuit par
des filières de colporteurs venus de
belgique et d'italie
la france est le pays européen qui à la
réglementation la plus sévère en la
matière ce soit des anabolisants et ce
qui signifie qu'ils augmentent chez des
animaux qui les ont reçus soit par voie
orale soit par voie d'injection ils vont
augmenter la synthèse des protéines et
surtout les protéines musculaires sait
qu'il va augmenter les masses
musculaires chez ces animaux
ce qui bien sûr augmente le rendement de
la production en viande chez les animaux
qu'ils ont reçu les estrogènes
naturelles sont rapidement dégradés pose
pas de problème de résidus en plus
estrogènes de synthèse notamment le
stilboestrol pause eu beaucoup de poèmes
de résilier ses résidus présente-t-il en
réel danger pour l'homme la législation
dit oui les endocrinologues eux sont
plus nuancés alors les conséquences
possibles de
l'administration d'estrogène lausanne yb
aux dépens de trois conditions
premièrement du sexe de l'individu qui
mangent la viande ainsi contaminés
deuxième mort la nature du produit qui a
été administré et troisièmement la
concentration de ce produit ces
concentrations est autant apprécié dans
la viande consommée que dans la durée de
consommation c'est-à-dire la quantité
totale du produit
je pense que même s'il s'agit de
produits non métaboliser c'est-à-dire
non détruits par l'organisme
il faudrait vraiment être un
consommateur exclusif de vaud pendant
des périodes extrêmement prolongé pour
ressentir objectivement les conséquences
de l'administration des hormones et des
estrogènes donc chez l'homme et car
c'est pratiquement uniquement chez
l'homme que le conséquences pourraient
être vu c'est à dire baisse de
l'activité génitales développement des
seins non je ne vois pas pourquoi ça
serait plus dangereux en d'autres termes
de manger une escalope de veau que de
prendre l'habitude animaux toujours pour
améliorer la race porcine le salut vient
de chine
en effet pour augmenter la production et
la rentabilité de l'élevage des porcs en
france l'institut de la recherche
agronomique a fait appel à neuf ports
chinois pur race pourquoi les chinois
et bien parce qu'ils recèlent des
qualités que nous voudrions bien donner
à nos propres cochon vous vous souvenez
de cette adorable cochon chinois de race
méchas il s'appelle maintenant tout
simplement joseph et c'est anne repas
pas l'expérience l'amélioration des
races françaises par croisements se
poursuit avec tours premiers résultats
la certitude que les ports chinois on
vient les caractéristiques espérer à
savoir prolificité peu de mortalité chez
les petits et puberté précoce
l'adaptation à la france n'a donc pas
poser de problème les six femelles
chinoises ont eu 70 porcelets et après
trois mois 58 sont encore vivants
l'inrap c'est donc une souche de ports
chinois qui sera conservé pour les
croisements
les premiers porcelets de pairs chinois
et de mer français sont un peu décevant
ce type de croisement direct ne favorise
pas la prolificité des femelles
française
en revanche les petits ont un nombre de
tétines équivalent aux femelles chinoise
plus il n'est donc pas impossible qu'à
la deuxième génération le nombre des
petits soient plus importants il y à un
autre point qu'il faudra vérifier à
savoir la qualité de l'engraissement de
ses ports croisés et le poids des
carcasses
cela n'a pas l'air très brillant mais
des améliorations ne sont pas
impossibles et pour l'instant il faut
attendre les premiers abattage ses
recherches dont les premières
conséquences vont aboutir dans deux ans
environ ont pour but de diminuer
l'important déficit de notre production
porcine en améliorant la rentabilité de
nos porcherie à cause du cyclone allen
la martinique vient d'être déclarée zone
sinistrée 842 personnes sont sans abri
dans l'île 1500 maisons endommagées et
les bananeraies ont été détruites à 100%
le cyclone pointe le nez vers le texas
qui a été mis en état d' alerte allen je
vous le rappelle draine des vents de 300
km/heure ce n'est pas le cyclone du
siècle comme on le dit parfois mais il
faut bien reconnaître qu'il est
particulièrement redoutable
sur ce cliché satellitaire reçu à
lannion en bretagne métropole française
cette masse blanche au milieu de la
caraïbe 7 le cyclone allen l'un des plus
violents de ce siècle ci n'est peut-être
pas le plus violent
c'était il ya quelques dizaines d'heures
mais maintenant genre d'honneur où
est-il exactement
un cyclone tropical allen est maintenant
situé au milieu du golfe du mexique et
ils se dirigent lentement à une vitesse
de la rente km heure vers les côtes
américaines
à la limite du texas et du mexique et si
vous restez dehors pendant un cyclone
voilà ce qui risque d'arriver des vents
cataclysmique des pluies de déluge des
vagues indescriptible
aucun superlatif n'est assez fort pour
décrire ce qu est un cyclone dans
quelques heures aux usa des hommes vont
mourir assurément remporté par une lame
écrasée sous leur maison ou noyée dans
une inondation
le record a été enregistré en 1970 au
bangladesh avec trois cent mille morts
on a aussi mesuré des vents de 350
km/heure des vagues de 30 mètres partout
ensuite le spectacle est désolant dans
des régions souvent sous développés et
qui ne se relève jamais d'un cyclone
trop puissant mais ont renversé forêt
anéanti toitures emportées plantations
rasé port détruit route effacés on
compterait dégâts par milliards de
francs lourd
partout dans le monde où sévissent des
cyclones qu'ils s'appellent selon les
régions typhon ouragans baguio wili wili
ce week-end c'est la même chose
allen est de ceux là ainsi qu une
exceptionnelle pas de doute c'est un
tueur
regardez ces taches blanches ronde ce
sont des cyclones jour après jour on les
voit deux satellites se former sur la
mer vaste tourbillon ramassé sur
eux-mêmes et qu'ils dépensent chaque
secondes l'équivalent de quatre à cinq
bombes atomiques de la puissance
d'hiroshima masse énorme de nuages
gorgés de pluie furoncle atmosphérique
vivent une dizaine de jours et qui se
nourrissent de la chaleur de la mer pour
prévoir leurs déplacements
on utilise beaucoup les satellites mais
aussi des avions américains pénétrant à
l'intérieur des phénomènes
là s'arrête le travail des hommes est-ce
qu'on peut dérouter ou détruire un
cyclone non si vous voulez considérant
ce cliché du mois doullens vernis qui
est relative aux cyclones david et
frederick voici david puis frédéric
david par exemple couvrait une
superficie avec 500 km de rayon
comment pourrions-nous intervenir pour
détruire l'énergie colossal qui est
induite dans ce cyclone
même les bombes atomiques ne sont pas
l'échelle de ce phénomène
je crois qu'en ce qui nous concerne des
registres nous pouvons c'est surveillé
ces phénomènes et étudier leur
trajectoire et leur évolution
on est donc condamnée à subir oui je
crois que l'homme subit ce phénomène et
ce phénomène est une catastrophe
là où il passe mais c'est aussi une des
composantes du bilan énergétique t rès
c'est aussi celui qui va dispenser les
pluies sur des régions alors supprimer
les cyclones envisager les supprimer s
est pas jouer à l'apprenti sorcier
car ils sont utiles quelquefois oui ils
sont une des composantes de la
circulation générale les supprimer c'est
aussi faux c'est le système
il y aurait donc des compensations
quelles seraient les conversations nul
n'en sait rien on ne joue pas avec la
nature et surtout pas avec les cyclones
en sport le roubaisien bruno lesaffre
vient de battre le record de france 2
400 m 4 nages en 4 minutes 38 secondes
et 80 centièmes cela s'est passé en
finale du championnat de france de
natation à brive puis en football vous
le savez repris ce soir du championnat
de deuxième division avec deux
rencontres
reims rennes et besançon toul le temps
demain sera beau dans l'ensemble
quelques ondées orageuses nous dit la
météo en début de journée des alpes à la
corse
mais cela s'améliorera et le temps assez
ensoleillé se généralisera le ciel
deviendra plus nuageux le soir près de
la manche comme vous le voyez sur cette
carte
quelques rendez vous avant de conclure
et de vous souhaiter une très bonne
soirée
le dernier journal à 22h40 avec paul
amar demain à 20h vous retrouverez léon
zitrone et deux mains à 12h45
samedi ennemi sera consacrée au jazz qui
connaît un renouveau certain en france
georges bégoux recevra beaucoup
d'invités et pour vous mettre dans
l'ambiance je vous propose de terminer
avec ce morceau de lutter à nice l1
rythmes de blues sur des images de
christian vidal
bonsoir